[Music]
you know i want to pay you a compliment
uh you co-wrote this book with your wife
jeannie who i've met
and um how is she i mean beautiful woman
she's great
she's beautiful i think you know all
three of us have done well
with our wives yes i don't know if you
encounter but my wife is
attractive to the point where people are
like wow like there's something wrong
like
like she might be blind or seeking
immigration papers it's like people say
that to their they act because you it
would be a little bit of an insult for
people to meet your wife and then look
at you it is strange i mean my wife's
very beautiful but it's not as if you
know i mean i'm not like a monster
but you know on twitter people are like
how'd you score that is she blind you
know it's very strange but that was me
uh that was you
i was trying to be funny uh all right so
uh what did you give her for mother's
day mother's day would you well i'm
always giving my wife gifts because i i
feel like i have to bribe her to keep
her to stay
but i uh
recently i i i bought my wife something
from victoria's secret i don't know if
you guys have ever done that and that's
that's very awkward you know
you know it's it's just awkward to be in
victoria secretary you went to the store
i went to the store
and as as a guy you need a reason to be
in victoria's secret you can't just be
in there kind of like i'm just looking
around
checking stuff out
but even even when you have a reason to
be in there as a man it's awkward that's
why every guy in victoria's secret has
that look like i'm shopping for a woman
it's not for me
it's very awkward and you know it's it's
a it's a male fantasy always you know
you look at victoria's secret and you
think i'm going to go in there and it's
just going to be like women walking
around in panties and angels wings
it's gonna be amazing yeah and then you
get in there and it's like a greyhound
bus station
what are you guys in between shifts here
you know
where are the angels
and and i don't know what i'm doing so i
went up to a sales clerk who has the
enthusiasm of like a tsa employee
you know and i'm just like uh you know
if you could help me get something from
my wife you know
and you can't be like i want a [ __ ]
outfit you have to be uh you know look
my wife she's intelligent uh she's
she's very creative
she volunteers often i i
i guess i'll just take that nurse outfit
and get out of here
it's humiliating yeah and then you fight
you think when you're paying for it it's
over but unfortunately then they give
you
your purchase in a victoria's secret bag
that you have to walk around with that
might as well just say pervert on the
top
and so
i tried to stuff it in my backpack so it
looked like i was stealing women's
underwear
it was and then i got home and my kids
were like you got me something i was
like just go to bed
it was it was awkward